right now the video game industry is
booming
sales of gaming hardware and accessories
have spiked as consumers have been
forced to stay home due to the
coronavirus pandemic
one of the biggest beneficiaries has
been sony maker of the playstation
its stock is surging profits are steady
and analysts predict
its newest system the playstation 5 has
the potential to be a major hit this
holiday
it's an impressive turnaround
considering six years ago
sony was on track to lose over two
billion
the electronics giant was being outsold
in everything from
tvs to smartphones by more nimble
competitors
here's how sony built its playstation
business like a heavyweight boxer
capable of going 12 rounds to pull the
company off the mat when it needed it
most
sony has been an electronics pioneer
since its founding
in the 1950s it was one of the first
companies to build radios with tiny
transistors
instead of vacuum tubes these transistor
radios were small
portable and became a massive hit for
the company
it was built around innovation whether
it be the transistor radio which was a
very compact
easy to use radio at the time the
trinitron television
and perhaps most famously the walkman in
1979 and that really put them
in the forefront of the global consumer
electronics industry in their first half
century
in 1994 the company leveraged this
innovation to enter the crowded video
game market
with a new console the playstation they
were not expecting you know
huge things out of it was just kind of
like hey this is kind of a side business
for us we'll launch a game system
i see what happens but the playstation
had two competitive advantages
under the hood the console ran on a
32-bit microprocessor
a huge leap over the 16-bit processors
of its predecessors
and unlike the rival nintendo 64 console
it played games on cds instead of
cartridges
this allowed for games to be made
cheaper and developers flock to
playstation
so they released uh thousands of games
for the sony playstation there was
something for everybody there was just
this diversity
of content that you didn't find with the
nintendo system over the next decade
sony gained market share and by 1999
was shipping more consoles than nintendo
kin kuduragi was the mastermind behind
the company's new gaming empire
ken kutaragi who was the head of the
playstation business from the beginning
was real maverick at sony wanted to run
his own business
so often clashed with other executives
at sony
and he wanted the machine with the
maximum specs he didn't want to
compromise on on the quality of the
hardware and the software
by the end of the 90s playstation sales
made up 40
of sony's operating profits and kudaragi
began developing a new system that would
be a trojan horse of digital home
entertainment
the playstation 2 was released in 2000
it featured a dvd player
and offered exclusive online play for
blockbuster games like madden football
and tiger woods pga tour
all game developers were committed to
sony and they
they realized that was their bread and
butter and sony was the system that was
going to deliver
uh the money for him that was until
microsoft released a gaming console of
its own
for the first time let me now unveil
xbox
the xbox was released in 2001 marking
the beginning of the modern console wars
that saw sony and microsoft battle for
gamers by offering exclusive titles
and packing their systems with different
features despite new competition
the playstation 2 dominated sales
eventually selling over 150 million
consoles
but all wasn't well at sony video game
sales were growing but profits were
declining in other divisions
so many of their products either were
commodified and it became the cheapest
is the best
or simply were overtaken by technology
to cope the company shed products and
laid off workers
a company as big as this one where
there's
such a wide variety of product has to
organize its priorities we we can't do
everything
the playstation became one of those
priorities
kuduragi was placed as head of the
company's next generation of electronics
and tasked with combining traditionally
siloed divisions
to integrate playstation technology into
other products
sony was looking at the playstation as
a driver of their whole consumer
electronics strategy
to pull this off the electronics maker
went all in in 2006 with its next
console
the playstation 3. the goal was to make
it the centerpiece of home entertainment
sony spent billions of dollars beefing
up the game machine with
state-of-the-art technology this
included a blu-ray dvd player
and a new supercharged microprocessor
called the cell chip
but the cutting edge console had
problems from the start
manufacturing complications with the
blu-ray player forced the release date
to be pushed back
allowing microsoft to grab a year head
start with its new system
the xbox 360. and the cell processor
proved to be
too powerful for its own good
frustrating game makers and gamers alike
gamers you know they like games before
anything else
and the playstation 3 was a game system
with all this other baggage that made it
cost
a hundred dollars more it was also
difficult
for developers to develop for the
playstation
3 versus uh the xbox 360.
a wildly successful nintendo wii console
and free mobile gaming cut deeply into
ps3 sales
by 2014 sony had suffered an annual loss
for four out of the previous five years
before the company had used its video
game business as a crutch
now it needed to use it as a lifeline
they really felt that there was
no other option but to really scale back
those products that were no longer
profitable on a large scale and really
focus on their winners
those winners included image sensors
sony made for smartphone cameras
and the playstation 4 which the company
had just released
at that point they really had no choice
but to uh put most of their
energy into the playstation because it
was the only product left
in the hardware side with growth
prospects to recapture gamers
experts say the company focused on what
made previous consoles successful
games it expanded its online ecosystem
by offering games that were free to play
through its playstation plus
subscription service
and it allowed cross console play for
popular titles like fortnite
meaning xbox and playstation gamers
could play together online
and sony really just lays our focus on
the idea of gamers
and having the best game
system out there versus the system
that'll do everything
by 2018 there were 34 million
playstation plus subscribers
creating a consistent gaming revenue
stream for sony beyond
selling consoles leading the company to
post record operating profits that year
and by 2020 sony's market cap had
reached 100 billion dollars
largely because of video games so
playstation 4 has had about 100 million
unit sales over the life of the machine
and
they say they want to exceed that over
the life of the playstation 5 and also
get off to a faster start that fast
start may be fueled by the recent rise
in video game related spending
but analysts say the new xbox consoles
will provide plenty of competition for
the playstation 5.
and for sony to stay in the ring the
electronics innovator will have to keep
innovating